[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas hoy excepcionalmente
desde París el mercado común del sur
También conocido como mercosur cumplió
32 años de existencia una Unión
económica entre Argentina Brasil
Paraguay y Uruguay que busca fomentar la
competitividad a través de la
integración y con ese objetivo se busca
ratificar un acuerdo con la Unión
Europea al tiempo que se trata de pactar
con china con las consecuencias que eso
puede traer para las empresas locales a
continuación nos adentramos en los
acuerdos del mercosur en la siguiente
pieza de los corresponsales de France 24
esta fábrica produce autopartes en
Buenos Aires actualmente funciona a
pleno rendimiento las exportaciones del
sector aumentaron un 11,6% en 2022 sin
embargo temen que esto se revierta
después del acuerdo entre mercosur y la
Unión Europea el sector Automotriz
podría ser el más afectado por el
acuerdo ya que la industria en Europa es
más competitiva y moderna y sus
vehículos no tendrían aranceles así lo
explican desde la asociación de fábricas
argentinas de componentes que
representan a más de 200 empresas para
un sector con más de 55.000 personas
empleadas que no haya inversión implica
que luego la producción de ciertos
productos ya no se haga o de ciertos
productos de nueva con nuevas
tecnologías se decida que no se hacen
acá se hacen en Europa eso implica que
va a haber menos demanda de mano de obra
en Uruguay el país vecino desde hace más
de 50 años Lancer
uniformes para empresas de todo el mundo
mercosur fue muy importante para el
textil uruguayo sobre todo durante
periodos de estabilidad ahora Uruguay
estudia un tratado de libre comercio con
china al margen de mercosur la cámara de
la vestimenta de Uruguay teme que el
sector pueda desaparecer con ese acuerdo
por la diferencia competitiva o sea
pantalones a una camisa algunas cosas
que todavía se siguen fabricando en
Uruguay y donde todavía somos un poco
competitivos así como estábamos
este Ahora sí de golpe desaparecen los
recargos y eso sería ya el punto final
de la Industria
a sus 32 años mercosur espera ratificar
en Julia el acuerdo con la Unión Europea
mientras discuten con Uruguay un acuerdo
con china en conjunto o uno separado que
podría resquebrajar la unión
en Perú la gripe aviar sigue afectando
la producción de pollo y los productores
avícolas estiman que la crisis se
mantendrá Más allá del mes de abril
provocando una alza de los precios ante
la escasez nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías visitó varios
comercios para traernos la siguiente
historia
[Música]
la gripe aviar obligó a los avicultores
peruanos a eliminar más de 850.000
gallinas en las últimas semanas
alrededor de 15 millones de apoyos
dejaron de nacer en un mes para el
productor Avícola y representante de
avisur al exgerí las pérdidas han sido
millonarias con la cantidad que se ha
eliminado han perdido entre 12 y 13
millones de dólares solamente en costo
de inversión sin contar la parte que tú
la producción te la estás no la vas a
tener eso también son un ingreso que no
va a producir para afrontar la
emergencia sanitaria que ha bajado de la
producción de pollos en un 25% el
gobierno anunció la importación de 17
millones de huevos fértiles para ser
criados en las granjas
una de las consecuencias el volumen de
pollo comercializado hoy es 7,2% menor
que el de hace un año Rosa Miranda ama
de casa Comenta que la Alimentación en
su hogar ha cambiado es igual No ya ya
no Uno no puede ya dar las porciones
como dabas No ya ya es menos ya las
porciones el kilo de pollo en los
mercados de Lima y su área metropolitana
promedia los 3,37 dólares 35% más caro
que un año atrás la inflación en Perú
fue del 9% anual en febrero con los
alimentos subiendo el doble impulsados
por el precio del
los restaurantes que venden pollo a la
brasa típica comida de los peruanos
también notan el sobrecosto y con eso
como siempre la clientela te va a bajar
porque ya el precio no es muy accesible
Y lamentablemente tenemos que pasar esta
situación afrontarlo porque no sabemos
qué va a pasar pues porque si se sigue
una cosa van a quebrar ese es el
problema
los peruanos esperan que las autoridades
avancen con la vacunación de pollos y
solución en la escasez y el alza del
precio Pero los avicultores advierten
que el proceso será lento
en los últimos años Brasil ha roto todos
los récords cuando de deforestación se
trata según datos oficiales en febrero
de 2023 la amazonía registró los peores
niveles de destrucción desde el 2015 sin
embargo no en todo el país es así en el
estado de Río de Janeiro se encuentra el
bosque urbano replantado más grande del
mundo y hasta allí llegó nuestra
corresponsal Valeria
parece una flor Está casi virgen pero se
trata de un bosque reforestado
incrustado en la segunda ciudad más
poblada de Brasil
este Parque Nacional fue ideado en el
siglo XIX por el emperador Pedro segundo
preocupado por la falta de agua en Río
de Janeiro décadas de cultivo intensivo
del café acabaron con la mata atlántica
la vegetación original de la región y
secaron los manantiales para esta
arquitecta fue una estrategia acertada
fue extremadamente importante además La
Floresta de tijuca propicia también un
clima más ameno en la ciudad ella
suavizó el calor que hacía en Río de
Janeiro
hoy es un rincón muy apreciado por los
turistas que visitan el Cristo Redentor
erguido en la montaña del corcovado
Isabel explica que Su riqueza no es solo
medioambiental en 2012 fue declarado
patrimonio mundial y cultural por la
UNESCO
el valor cultural del parque se debe
primero al hecho de haber sido una gran
área reforestada por el hombre además
hay varios puntos hermosos en el parque
que son verdaderamente atractivos Grutas
diques capillas antiguas haciendas de
café que fueron expropiadas y
convertidas en restaurantes
El desafío ahora es preservar esta
Floresta y mejorar su hábitat la
directora cuenta que hay un programa
para reintroducir animales como macacos
a guties y Tucanes
La Floresta de tijuca hoy demuestra
cuánto un área reforestada puede
contribuir con la vida del ser humano
por ejemplo con la producción del agua
hoy una parte de la ciudad Se abastece
gracias al agua que sale de este bosque
si no existiese el parque de tijuca
tendríamos otra realidad en esta ciudad
estas cascadas son la prueba viva de que
es posible recuperar entornos devastados
por el hombre
en Ecuador una iniciativa de mujeres
indígenas Busca reducir la deforestación
y también el uso de derivados del
petróleo a través de las llamadas
cocinas ancestrales un proyecto que
combina la eficiencia energética con la
preservación de las costumbres
culinarias el siguiente es un reportaje
de nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
Natividad Méndez prepara los alimentos
tradicionales con leña de la forma
ancestral indígena ahora usa una cocina
ecológica construida con ladrillos donde
una placa de acero se convierte en la
fuente de calor para reducir el uso de
la madera en un 90%, no utiliza gas
licuado ni energía eléctrica es una
fuente alternativa de eficiencia
energética que empieza a dar resultados
la cocina en sí es más más limpia más
rápida una y otro en cuestión de la leña
no utilizo bastante simplemente ahí le
meto un poco de leña eso permanece
caliente
a un recolectar madera para calentar
este caldero
[Música]
como ella el 40% de su comunidad sufre
de afecciones respiratorias por la
contaminación del humo la gripe y la
garganta porque me sabe dar las
amígdalas o la tosma la tos más me da
esperamos ocho días Viviana kaluki es
una de las responsables del proyecto de
las cocinas ecológicas asegura que esta
forma artesanal de eficiencia energética
además de reducir el impacto en la salud
también disminuye en un 85% la
deforestación de bosques utilizamos el
15% de esta porción de leña y esta
porción de leña cuando se le mete en la
en la cuando se lo coloca en la cocina
ecológica prácticamente te diré que pasa
más de un día más de un día caliente que
se puede seguir cocinando sin que sin
necesidad de ir colocando más leña
la reforestación de bosques es la
segunda fase de este proyecto con el que
aspiran sembrar cada año 130.000 nuevas
especies de plantas en 12 asentamientos
de los indígenas Muchas gracias por
seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana también desde París siga con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]
[Aplausos]